ho trasformato in una gallina cerchiamo
di non attivare queste tre board è
questo un drago è venuto in asta oggi
come potete vedere dalle nostre
magliette a righe torneremo escape lug
prigione la prigione del castello una
nuovissima prigione bellissima dove
sempre lasciato mi piace anzi provati
alla sera bibbia centro o 3 3 2 2 verona
territorio non mi seguite interazioni
integra mandate a seguirmi e ora
iniziamo sometimes ai promo e così qua
siamo quale la prigione io avevo un
bellissimo vestitino rosa ma allora cosa
stiamo in prigione l'hanno cambiato con
questa tutina da prigioniera la
maglietta con scritto il mio nome così
almeno non posso confondere perché tu
hai la maglietta io no vabbè questo il
nostro letto da prigionieri delle ore
prima c'è stato un prigioniero prima di
noi ma non gli è andata molto bene ma se
premi e parla descritto le guardie sono
infausta quindi questa è la nostra
occasione per scappare o che scriviamo
si allora meglio del rock scherzano
capito un po crollato tutto
non hai attento ehi ma tu sei ancora lì
si capisce ritardi indovinate quante
volte si spara accellera vitale questa
volta ma soprattutto vincerà di the
hobbit era vitale
di abusi definizione riina non ci credo
vitalista profitto ho preso questa
chiave che c'è una spada che bella qua
altre ossa di prigionieri fortunati ne
sono chiamo sacro adoro già troppo
questa regione
c'è una gabbia è di evitare se continui
a mangiare e di metterla dentro
piccoli campioni qui no una botola
segreta fare ma forse qui sul pavimento
e lava e fa quello accaduto e sono io
vivevo saltare secondo l'aggiornamento
attento i pasti per che esplodono ok dai
eco vitale se lavori pari sono non ce lo
fa su cielo vabbè io saluto braccia al
grammo dovrà usare questa chiave c'è
scritto che ho preso una chiave segreta
attento perché questo crolla quindi
piangiamo vitale sfracellato io non mi
sono ancora scarse la caf non è
possibile
vediamo se vitale si sfracella che fa o
no quadrano il viaggio questa parte
questo miglia all'altra escape rumore
dei sotterranei che abbiamo fatto non
avete regalato si appalta sulla testa
delle guardie per
farli venire tipo e tu mettono le
guardie
vediamo se vitale si sfracellano ti ha
spiattellato nella raccolta già che
questo sarà difficile non basta
difficile ma perché mi fa volare così
sono finite pure dal castello come fuori
dal castello sono riuscito a passare il
primo scaltri sopra la testa valutare
tipo un cavaliere inizio
sono uscita subito attraversare tutto 60
di sopra
[Applauso]
che bel super divertente perché per me
assomiglia appunto alle altre skip look
era un capi sognava trovare la chiave da
ti ricordi allora quello no non ci credo
mi ha trasformato in una gallina
trasformato in una galleria a continuare
l'escape room come una gallina papà ti
frega vediamo se anche c'è chi ha
ragione
basta considerare sempre come gallini
come nuovo bello mi ha mangiato gli ho
mangiato quel baule quei valori che ha
mangiato meno male a un e mi ha mangiato
almeno non sono più una gallina è il
primo è il fatto considera chiave come
la braun sono scappati che sei stato
quindi bruciamo baule rimanete questo
aspetto presterà il baule della gallina
dice che se dove trovare alla chiave uno
di questi gesti dove tiene questa è
quella che sa quel che dice è una chiave
è gialla che ho preso io adesso che apro
questa porta
ok hai visto bravo ma io non posso
continuare a fare mistero un cortese no
tu che stai facendo guarda anche da
gallina sono riuscite a stare attenta
perché qui mi sa che ci sono questi
spuntoni questa è una trappola
guardate noi per un bello stop basa
anche se devo dire che questa gallina e
molto molto agile e dove è finito vip
ecco mi aspetto vitale dai ce la puoi
fare
e con attenzione cosa ci teniamo a
saltare guerra come tanto bene da kelly
lavoro anche fuori e si sono portato la
sua in continuazione e poi vola un po
con le ali hanno rinunciato solo io ne
anima cammina ha trovato bello se anche
tu fossi stato trasformato in un tris
hoc da casa e casini non lo farei più
vitale andiamo allora io dovevo essere
cardinal però devo dire che adesso mi
sto affezionando a questa gallina sito
capitolo attenti una trappola e me ne
sono accorto di questo pavimento per
conto di avere l'ok e rispettare
vediamo cosa c'è qua come fattori como
ma c'è un agguato qui la proprio ad
eliminarlo si fa è stato in testa per
salvare sconfitta uova d'oro questo
cartello mi ricordo il castello di un
vero equilibrio ma purtroppo non
cantiamo che dice vediamo ora dobbiamo
abbassare il ponte impostando la leva
dalle acque
wow by mancano delle parti in questo
punto stai moverman e sono aperto guarda
la guardia è gratuita ma come c'è
tantissima guardi a quello sbrigati che
ci sono le guardie figer si riprendono
non so come ho fatto ma sono riuscita a
fare il pienone si aspettano memoria
minuto sono cattivissime fare questo
sono tantissime perché troppo dietro
scappa scappa g dolcissimo oa 30 qui a
questa trappola per fortuna hanno smesso
di inseguirci ma adoro questo per delle
bellissime enorme che stende televisivi
preferiti per titoli
se volete molto bene dire trasformino in
caso di arrivo a tre che ci sono le
guardie va benissimo con la spada e con
la soubrette che succede
mi sa che i ponti 4 alla moda preghiamo
brighiamo cc 66 difettato normale non
sei più gallina si te l'ho detto dopo
che sono stata bruciacchiata nel male è
purtroppo mi ero affezionata cosa vuol
dire stabilizzare sta andando molto
meglio con il pescara 53 sprofondamenti
è andato molto meglio allora secondo te
come funziona qui bisogna evitare i fili
in rame sono trappole sé perché se non
si attivano tipo ottima gino 9 di
mattina non sono fatto per un premo ci
sono come si chiama
no era distinto scusa non so cos'è ykk
resa scusa mai arrivata la fama di
magellano
vabbè stato molto che sono sfracellato
io arrivo
eccomi qua qua guarda punta napoli ma va
penso che stia diventando sempre più
difficile anche se il super divertente
locale di vedere tutte le altre stanno
riscaldando più mia replica male ha
fatto saltare le facile è facile e sono
gelato dai dai dai possiamo farcela oplà
io no non era marmore meglio che mi
sfracellasi
dai puoi farcela in effetti è un po
difficile far correre cubitale ce la
farà sono parlamentari
avete notato che io e nel videogioco o
gli orecchini a forma di fragola e anche
nella realtà italiana
salviamo subito vediamo e tenta le
trappole l'ultima persona ha toccato il
patimento quindi non dobbiamo toccare il
pavimento
forse non bisogna proprio toccare il
pavimento tremare bimbi l'ultima per
fare rimasta lì pianto bari se stai
attento che ho capito era come quelle
skype room sempre della prigione nel
sotterraneo
se tutto che il pavimento si spia si
chiama e quindi sei molto molto music
cloud come non detto da qualcuno giocare
un'altra casa pari negli attacchi
durante l'e3 per room dei sotterranei
che cos'è successo
che cosa è successo che tu mi da
giustificare 10.000 volte tre putt
l'arte è arrivato anche qualcun altro
non tira è un po dobbiamo salvare
dobbiamo assolutamente salvare questo
guarda questo deve essere il campiello
abbiamo che dice questo tempio montato
da questo tempio chissà questa se dentro
dobbiamo dobbiamo entrare dentro alla
bocca di qualcuno è nuovamente
questo è un tempio fatto di pietra non
ci saranno quei problemi ries però
sapete che cosa stiamo parlando pero ci
sono delle problematiche ma va bene vi
abbia un ultimo scendendo nei
sotterranei abbiamo di toro qui c'è
qualcuno che mi succede o quella cosa lì
che gira dobbiamo sapere sul lavoro la
barca ha detto c'è una zattera qua in
italia bisogna premere ok ma bisogna
militare sta votando no caffè ferrotto
si gustano tutte quelle lametino
nell'enorme il capitolo a guidare dai
sapere come la guidiamo che guida non
capisco come avviso come 60 aiuto a
qualcuno ma io non ho capito perché avrà
subito un'altra persona già visto che
viene scappato ha detto che questi non
sembrano guida 2000 è vero che qualcuno
vi rilassate lo seguivamo aiuto penso a
guidare ma che succede
siamo rimasti bloccati per fare tutto e
coloro che partono se dovesse capitare
la zattera
no ci sono studiare anche quante bisogna
stare attenti e aspettare che passi
quella quella parte con le lame lì e poi
partire che qualcuno perché qualcun
altro
non lo so lo so perché non ha funzionato
ha funzionato non si prendono e vabbè
allora io sono nella tratterà con un
altro giocatore aiuto dai forse ce l'hai
fatta
io ho tirato una leva spero che funzioni
in patria ma dovrà farlo entro
aspettarmi aiuto aiuto
forse bisogna andare dall'altra parte
prendere la stretta vado ecco perché non
riuscivamo 31 mettersi con il cane o all
autore o troppo vediamo se con viale
giannotti che leone ma deve uscire un
uomo d'onore riusciamo a distruggere
anche un intero secondo me alla fine
bisogna saltare e anche se il galeone e
distrutto saltare per la salvezza allora
è però qualcuno deve premere la barra
pronti secondo vertenza quando lo
premiamo adesso fai
vado subito a serve aiuto aiuto cosa ci
facciamo poco alla fine salta arrivi
alla fine salta sì sì mi guardo si vive
più fatto non si preso tu sei qui non è
vero siamo sopravvissuti all'incidente
del gal e alla punta di ciano guardia
dobbiamo assolutamente fare
e facciamo guarda ti trovi bene e
un'altra più brava vabbè mi sono chiesta
in prigione topolino io sono rimasto di
sterline nell'ascensore
adesso lo chiamò la ciociara e facete o
no
sono rimasta bloccata tipo in un varco
spazio temporale forse perché ho
chiamato io l'ascensore infatti
l'assenza in giornata giulia moretto
volando a non essere sfracellata auguri
a te siamo arrivati qualche paura
tipo generò così per esempio di jones
ok pronti ad entrare nel tempio male se
ne siamo pronti vediamo cosa ci dice
questo posto è molto spaventoso stai
attento alle trappole
se vedi qualche scheletro stata tagliata
testo on ora alle guardie oltre le parti
sono di e cerchiamo di non attivare
queste tre volti noti che stai molto
attento perché non c'è anche a me anzi
mi spiace che amy trasformi in polpette
io sto super attento tu stai attenta il
piano ma qui c'è una griglia prima tv è
attento su ti sei anche salvato dai ti
aspetto qui però mi volevo scusare scusa
evitarono fatto apposta da essi così
arrivata ok
eccomi qua un corretto credo come fa
qualcuno la serie sito e per il mio
braccio affetta devo rifare non rifare
questa qui ma sono finita fuori dal
castello gubbio pur i pori dai possiamo
farcela sta diventando veramente
veramente difficile questo qui si è
staccato però si passa prima uno e poi
l'altro è ok forse è meglio uno alla
volta e così quella voi non lo sapete ma
siamo stati fermi mezz'ora tipo di là in
quella parte lì cui arrivano gli
spuntoni perché qualcuno ha deciso di
fare il simpatico e ogni volta che
passava qualcuno premeva il pulsante
schiacciava tutti quanti decisamente un
orali a non far passare nessuno
all'importante che ora sia unita al
mondo possiamo continuare le nostre t
per un bar da qui tante ovviamente ok
pro preso vita tenuto gli schemi tribù
che avevi saltarli in testa troviamo una
e poi porge la nello scheletro riprende
vita
stai molto attento anche degli istanti
sono scappato c'è un'altra scheletro
attento saltato addosso tenta questo
scheletro c'è una scelta di corridori
che si raggiunga ok abbiamo salvato ma
bisogna prendere la leva a noi appena
ammazzato qualcuno li come io do tutto
sotto a malta sbrigati 26 quasimodo
quindi se premi l'aveva scompare
commissione via
bisogna salire sopra il più velocemente
possibile
anche questa parte è difficilissima di
vista dire fino imprecisione penso
proprio di sì e difficilissimo accesso a
un certo punto diventa super complicato
perché bisogna saltare al contrario di
cantare testa mi capitò super difficile
è una delle fibre room più difficile
massimo moratti
possiamo farcela possiamo farcela ok dai
dai dai dai dai dai noi possiamo far
saltare il mio caso è difficile come
sempre non ci credo vitale sulle quattro
medici lista
e attenta perché sta cambiando direzione
ha quindi come direzione di sale di oboe
più alte piante che abbia ok ok
che c'entra prioletta che lascia da quel
lato vai adesso salta bravo ok ci sto
conserviamo aspetta però adesso spetta a
me no non facevo in tempo e hope
lavorava e quindi un po di rincorsa si
suoi non si sposta giusto non ho mai
rossetti e ora stabilire
non vedo più di entrava non aspetta il
nostro prossimo
ecco bene ancora due si sono poi io sono
di tale regola prima di carpa aiuto
aiuto aiuto dai traguardi
sì stiamo aspettando quire casa ha detto
bravo avvertiva allora come funziona e
non devi premere i fili penso sono delle
trappole
wow comunque ho premuto il film che è
colpa mia
scusate colpa mia scusa cos'è quella con
trappole che al massimo tecca o no
non fate tutte proviamo dai possiamo
farcela possiamo fare ce l'ha fatta
un film ok provato io ti aspetto 4 viamo
uno alla volta perché i promo è davvero
una delle più difficili che abbiamo mai
fatto forse la più difficile di tutte
sei stata tu vero è anche se io stavo
dietro le ditte di starace mon amour
ward difficilissimo un credo che siamo
riusciti a superare questa parte
56 penso sempre
vediamo cosa si dice alta su un cavallo
e vai al canyon che bello che bello che
bello mio tomaia parli che cavalli prete
o questo che non si è bello ma dovete
fare non lo so
deve saltare e che succede
roma è fantastica anche andare a cavallo
al castello e fantasma super divertente
molto meno capelli non benissimo quindi
stare molto attenti cerca riscatto
cavano benissimo evitare dopo e fino io
questo sfracellando un po di una volta
insomma bisogna correre impattare ma le
settimane dal cavallo e libero adesso
aspetto non sta ne vantiamo
vediamo se vediamo vitale d'acqua col
cavallo e copiare la giuda e puoi
farcela vita e buoni e latte che se ne
provare tutto michael morto fortissimo
[Musica]
[Risate]
divertenti questa partita non bellissima
se una guardia si ok messa fuori uso
prende ora sembrare vediamo c'è una
grana levante che prima la leva cos'è
mare dove filiere sarebbe uscito su su
su su fantastico questo castello io ad
ora troppo le spie per un'unica noli che
è successo cioè rimaste mezz'aria sì
qualcuno deve essere salito nella
scienza ci sono delle guardate bocca è
attento e salta di testa
questo che sta picchiando scappata ma io
ho scelto la via di fuga
no fortunatamente notte abbiamo questa
un drago d'oro che dobbiamo fare qui
possiamo più stare attento al fuoco del
drago ed animata che salvo di cosa
dobbiamo fare
tia bruciacchiare ok allora proviamo a
dire vediamo se riusciamo evitare il
drive hashemita aspettato se tipo una
botola non e bloccando come bloccato non
capisco come si sa bene dobbiamo per
forza affrontare il drago sputafuoco
super divertente provare a donne 3
sfrutta chiaro e bruciato vitale
bruciacchiati city mitico non ti
prendono devi riuscire ad arrivare qua
degli angoli via roma
via via via miu miu miu miu miu via pia
via pia via pia nell'angolino ma
nell'angolino
io sono fatta wow ecco la tecnica per
riuscire però a versare prima che sputa
in foto negativa relativa all angolino
e adesso dobbiamo passare sotto le sue
gambe non so aiuto possiamo so credo si
ecco la coda del drago ma quelli lì a
spiaccicare tutti che se siano altre
guardi qua con ade giganti aiuto se ne
sono stabili sopra avvisare se dentro il
castello il dottore ma il dottore per
salvare ha detto non prenderemmo
avventura pazzesca dentro a questo
castello che bello attenta qui c'è 14
arrivando ok sono qui e che cosa questo
rumore
non lo so ma fa un po paura ci sta
succedendo attenta questa guardia presa
guadagna un bel perché qui puoi salvare
abbiamo salvato
ora bisogna dare una realtà molto
lentamente cercate amano avevo capito
che bisognasse passato stiamo proprio
sopra il castello
a questi su questi rumori sono con gli
spuntoni mi vedi come facciamo bastare
luce tipo una sequenza che dobbiamo
seguire sia fatto di serie ci sono
anch'io
questa è la famosa scacchiera rob la
super difficile si no
uffici tutti i nemici sultan ci sono la
loro testa c'è una brutta notizia per te
per completare questi prumo e dobbiamo
andare nell'arena incardina livello qua
e sconfiggere tutti i nemici fare
dobbiamo prendere 20 a testa
29 siamo dei gladiatori che filetti
presidente solo spappolata era presente
anche vetro no però sonori che ti
rimangono sa bene non è così difficile
ma meno male almeno non realizzi da capo
se non pensare che siano più interattivi
non quello nero più cattivo quindi sì ne
ho eliminato quindi non spetta
incorrotto qua ma troppo divertente
queste skipper romperà il ninja col
primo caso di ogni minuto medio
tutto a tutto si ferma 10 visto non fu
panda adesso i bar c'era illuminare
il radiatore il sito
bene ora che cosa sappiamo qui spero che
questa posta e la prova finale ci
vediamo io voglio assolutamente prendere
il medaglione dov'è ma è qui dove allo
studiolo chrome è stata veramente
regolare
sì ma è stata bellissima anche se devo
dire che era molto difficile da una 10 a
voi che voto date privati tutti i
commenti scritti si vostri momenti
preferiti del tempo con il minuto e dato
che è memoria del signor e ora vi
lasciamo con la faccia sentire niente
qui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video in casa su quella che preferite
buona visione
[Applauso]